hey guys it's Jonah here so a balanced
meal requires protein carbs healthy fat
vegetables and also fruits protein is
extremely important to build and
maintain muscle mass and also to speed
up muscle recovery so your protein
intake were very according to your
activity level but the general
recommendation is one gram of protein
per one kilogram of your bodyweight so
for instance my weight is 50 kilograms
so my protein intake should be about 50
grams but because I'm active I will up
my protein intake to about 60 to 70
grams per day I know a lot of us tend to
get worried that we're not consuming
enough protein but if you consume a
balanced diet it is not that hard to
meet your daily requirement if you're a
vegan I'm sure you must have come across
at least one person asking you when you
get your protein from or saying that
you're not consuming enough protein I'm
sure you would agree that this is not
true
there are so many high protein
plant-based foods such as nuts and seeds
legumes beans quinoa tofu soya oatmeal
and more so I'm gonna share with you a
high protein plant-based meal plan for
breakfast let's make tofu baked muffins
for the cross you'll need two cups of
potatoes grated 1 tbsp of olive oil and
also a pinch of salt and pepper
as for the filling you'll need 200 grams
of firm tofu sliced into cubes 3 garlic
cloves diced 1 medium onion diced 1 cup
of spinach 1/3 cup of cherry tomatoes
1/2 1/3 cup of mushroom thinly sliced
1/3 cup of red bell pepper diced
pre-heat your oven to 200 degrees
Celsius let's start by prepping the
crust
place the grater potatoes onto a clean
kitchen towel and firmly squeeze out the
excess moisture then transfer the potato
into a dish drizzle with olive oil and
season with salt and pepper divide into
6 equal portions and press the shredded
potatoes
into a muffin tray to form the crust
bake for about 20 to 30 minutes or unto
crunchy and golden brown and set aside
while the crust is baking we want to
cook the feelings in a pan heat oil over
medium-high heat stir in the garlic
onion bell pepper mushrooms cherry
tomatoes and spinach saute for about 3
to 4 minutes or until vegetables are
slightly tender and spinach is wilted
then season with a pinch of salt and
continue to stir and set aside next
let's prep the tofu filling so add the
tofu and a pinch of salt to a food
processor and blend until smooth if it's
too thick then add a little bit of water
set aside once the crust is ready remove
from the oven and we want to fill it up
with the cooked vegetables and top up
with the tofu mixture then return to the
oven and bake for another 10 to 15
minutes or until the tofu is
golden-brown and firm remove from oven
and allow the muffins to cool down the
tofu will continue to firm up as the
muffin cools down for most vegans tofu
is a huge part of your diet it contains
10 grams of protein a half cup serving
so tofu is also very low in calories and
great for weight loss but then so the
tofu is of the higher the protein
content so firm tofu has higher protein
content in comparison to silken tofu and
when it comes to buying tofu always opt
for the organic version to avoid a
genetically modified soya or any harmful
pesticides which can do more harm than
good if you consume 3 tofu muffins for
breakfast you will be having 339
calories and 14.5 grams of protein plus
2 servings of vegetables spinach is a
great green leafy vegetables to enjoy as
much as you want and it is high in
protein so one cup of cooked spinach has
more than 5 grams of protein so this is
a great breakfast to kick start your day
for lunch
let's make chickpeas tofu scramble wrap
this recipe is convenient and you can
just grab and go when you need it what
you'll need are half a can of chickpeas
100 grams of firm tofu cut a cup of
cherry tomato half cut a cup of red bell
pepper diced cut a cup of onion diced 1
tablespoon of olive oil 1/2 a teaspoon
of turmeric powder half a teaspoon of
garlic powder half a teaspoon of smoked
paprika and also 8 inch whole-wheat
tortillas in a pan heat oil over
medium-high heat add onions and also
firm tofu bell pepper and cherry
tomatoes saute for three to four minutes
or until the vegetables are tender then
add in the chickpeas continue to cook
until all ingredients are heated through
stir in the seasonings smoked paprika
garlic powder turmeric and salt next
take one wrap and place about quarter
cup of the feeling near the center roll
tightly and serve this recipe is
extremely versatile
I love the Nazi and earthy flavor of
chickpeas but of course you can replace
it with other beans of your choice you
can also mix other vegetables or replace
the rack with pizza bread make it a
sandwich or just enjoy it on its own so
one wrap provides you with 254 calories
and 9 grams of protein have two wraps
for lunch as for dinner my favorite is
the attempt at chili con carne this dish
is bursting with flavors what you'll
need are 2 tablespoons of olive oil
divided 1 cup of tempeh cut into cubes 2
teaspoons of soy sauce 1 red bell pepper
diced 1 cup of zucchini cut into cubes 1
carrot diced 2 garlic cloves minced 1
medium onion diced 1 can of black beans
1 can of diced tomatoes 1 tablespoon of
smoked paprika 1/2 a teaspoon of cumin
powder quarter teaspoon of cayenne
pepper 1 cup of curved
right so use about one tablespoon of
olive oil and salted the tempeh until it
is slightly golden brown just for about
three to five minutes then add in the
soy sauce and saute for another minute
until the soy sauce is sticky and
dissolved and set aside with the
remaining one tablespoon of olive oil
saute all the vegetables garlic onion
carrot zucchini and bell pepper then add
the seasonings smoked paprika cumin
powder and cayenne pepper next stir in
the black beans chopped tomatoes and
tempeh allow all the ingredients to
simmer for about 20 to 30 minutes until
the sauce thickens don't forget to stir
occasionally and if necessary add some
water finally garnish with coriander and
serve with a side of rice some of you
might not even have heard of temper but
if you get a chance to do give it a try
tempeh is a fermented form of soya
that's high in protein easy to digest
and reach in probiotics it has 12 grams
of protein per cup it is nutty chewy and
has a distinct flavor you might not
enjoy temper on your first few tries but
do give it a try again and eventually
you will grow to love the texture and
also taste black beans are my favorite 1
cup of cooked black beans has 15 grams
of protein and it is also low English
scenic index this means by adding that
beans into your diet you will feel full
and satisfied for a long time and it is
also great for weight loss so this one
serving with rice has 421 calories and
23 grams of protein all this recipes can
be prepped ahead and you can keep them
in the fridge for after three days so
add two quarter cup servings of trail
mix as part of the snacks and you will
be meeting your daily protein
requirements of 67 grams of protein
which is enough for my activity level
and to maintain a good health so guys it
is possible to get your protein from
plant base
what's your favorite plant-based source
of protein let me know in the comments
below try this recipe out snaps and
share your cooking with me attack me at
Joanna so official and hashtag chaser
recipes don't forget to also subscribe
to my youtube channel for a lot more
healthy recipes and also workout videos
do also turn on your notification button
so that you will get notified every time
I share a new video all the best